hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III stage I'm your host Mike McCarty
here with GameSpot's Miguel concepción
all right and we are pleased to be
joined by category Yamauchi the founder
of polyphony digital and creator of Gran
Turismo it's great to have you and taco
you'll be interpreting and kind of
hanging out with us as well yep yeah
great so uh yeah we got to see more of a
GT Gran Turismo sport at Sony's press
conference the other day and that's
you've been since showing it off and
everything how's uh what's it like to be
kind of showing it more you know as we
lead it to the release these Majdanek
when yeah yo got the casino Dona Kansas
came up here to sue the snare Innokin
coionei a no.19 open ah co-product oh no
zessica no saigo no mock demise a Shanda
arrival if I meant oh no Stacy ma sucah
Anka Katherine's name is Caracas loca by
macaw got a token even Disney
Tech yeah no comedy
samatha man apart oh no quality Oates
met a grant a smooth great animal coach
a Savino Putin on oh dae-su Quattro to
walk walk west emotion yeah so you know
we're really at the last portions of our
development right now we're really
really taking a time to optimize and we
find everything and you know right now
the the quality of the game is just
rising exponentially and we're at the
end well as we you know really go go
down to details and polish everything
and it's something that we actually
haven't been able to do for for a while
in the past editions of the game it's
probably since the original one that we
actually have been able to do really
take the time to really do the final
touches into the game sure yeah I guess
my major question is what sets Gran
Turismo sport apart from the rest of the
series
um you said we were talking before there
there was like a huge reason behind why
it's not like a numbered title or
anything or why it's called GG sport but
you know as someone who's played all the
games and I'm not great at them but uh
admittedly but you know someone who's
played all these like what is it that'll
set GT sport apart from you know all the
other games
children sake on alright I'm a GT sport
a sport numbering is exposed not a video
Missoni
Scottie what I do society though what
comedy on Gran Turismo asamdigdha play
needed high branches of sport in one
mile is a new title to market a kimchi
on sugar today so the snare no mohamed
el gran turismo dehydrator teacher
should I take a business coach you know
deck that's a fun kind of Gran Turismo
sport to take after speakers a featured
video rather Mohito a sports modest
Marvin Scott amount of the high
telescopes the photography skiddo Mike
Oliver online Don champion so no gonna
Maserati body editor Oliva escapes for
you Martha see HDR photography no sekai
no comeback
let's go under so net sports for you in
a walk when my dad but not this much my
to go straight honest itself good
medicate and I could a policy if he
serve a Heidi cut through paradise level
to the schedule pretty motivated on Tom
confident acai perfect on a money not to
do this on neck yeah so you know Gran
Turismo sport it's a title that actually
contains all the different features that
we've had you know in the past titles of
the series it's actually has the most
number of features or anything released
before so it contains a lot of new
features you know we have the first
first off we have the sports mode which
is the which is what the game is really
named for you know involves the online
Championships that we're going to be
running throughout the year we have the
livery editor we have the escapes
feature which is really kind of opens up
a new world in HDR photography so you
know GT sports is a title that you know
it contains up everything we had in the
past plus new features and it's a title
that we've been able to really take the
time to perfect to the level that you
know we are that we're satisfied with
Yale you got the chance to play the beta
right yes I played the beta took on a
lot of hardcore fans and some of my
media colleagues I was thinking about
this emphasis on online play would you
say that GT sport leans towards or
encourages playing online or is there a
substantial single-player component I
don't know how do clinically add to a
bit on in cyclic team immediately on
Tigers the more studies on the schedule
I know Mulligan was good my hitta
Tyson Plano like they need to cast are
again not on this car I look glassy
small sports was a tiny Matata soyita
map really a competition Yudhoyono
online you go she do anniversary Tomo
so no crying no potion no game on did
someone alarm a super dope
so the snare an improved ability so debo
croco Connaughton wha
Messiah cross the beta tester pacion
apart instead bugarach remedy against a
button on a phone toe knee chest
occasional Paulo de la Riva cross Zometa
test OD at across da betta demo de una
FATA no more mama free decay grandes
Cosmo peach a carnival a a no sports
mode Americana and no buckwheat chicken
okay so the closed beta test is actually
you know it really is just a test it's
something that that really tested out
the parts that we need we didn't have
experience with that we really need the
additional data to to finalize and so
it's really is something that's that can
only be called a closed beta test it's
not it's not a demo per se in that
respect and what you experienced in the
closed beta test is really one sliver of
all the things that's going to be
offered within your Gran Turismo sport
so Ted Anto motor on una segunda in demo
ho kanaeva opened OD toca Boca friend
Oleta mo da SATA no scenario
democracy at all now orangutan is very
campaign mode resemble a Jacuzzi vent
open and a sore neck on the impression
is Matteo us take you back a divan act a
miss it all promoted or even on to this
one domain no party no alignment a demo
and online no sorry some attacks on a
stereo dinner webinar distance so you
know the online portion actually you
know also has an open lobby which wasn't
available in the beta test also where
you know you would be able to just have
fun and friendly races with a friend
Brett things like that and then the
campaign mode actually contains a 145
events so we're not trying to really
direct everyone to online it has a
pretty significant online portion like
the previous titles in the past you know
where that's actually the main part and
then you know we it's just that we have
a lot more online stuff to offer as well
not sure yeah a big part of beta is from
my understanding right is getting like
feedback and kind of stress testing the
game before it comes out is there
anything you learned during the beta
that you have since implemented that
that will be their final release a bit I
dunno but if you do become autonomous to
this test totally acceptable okay now
walkie this for me
oh no tsunami Toccara Anoeta Zoho Dave
mom Sydney I don't use the Hank are
Italian raka I think what encoding Adi
internet taxonomy a ghetto
stop Oh Tony okay - Pony Gran Turismo
neck ramadhan OCD so a fun day greta
Sandow you
no seppuku fences techni no feedback
cormorant a para Homolka Nagato sedated
a happiness tatata penguia emoni Sabah
crayon toget a note I see no Bible no
NASA bono FK no bucum salute oh hey
sports masquerading Africa called track
to the collision of fettucini management
assistant optimism or an O so fond of
any kind of hydaburg with academics
there a gyno today Bassam Thomas Odyssey
Oliva a game you i'ma solar sea oh
camera position Masada Sigma soy taco -
no feeder Bakumatsu boo boo crying -
Terrapins constantly so yes the from the
beta we had a lot of different types of
feedback you know I think you know we
had because we had so many of the
longtime users of baptism of the
longtime fans of graduates were
participating in the beta we really got
a lot of constructive feet constructive
feedback from them so you know our
objective was originally was just to get
you know really the test out the server
client client matching the system and
also really to test out the server loads
but you know any this and we needed to
really sort of figure out the the
balance of the sportsmanship ratings for
the game and also the
document that song yeah but I guess the
the the collision judgment system okay
as well yeah that's something that you
know that required your feedback and
adjustment and that's what we did but we
also got a lot of constructive feedback
from the users regarding the other parts
of the game such things such as sound
and you think such as the UI you know
how the how the cameras are positioned
so it was a it was a very useful
learning experience for us as well
looking back on the series and the way
that the game the individual games
demanded to unlock the various cars I
recall spending these new spent at least
five hours just to unlock a twenty
different kinds of skylines which seemed
a little time-consuming can you describe
how the unlock system in this game works
if it's like how many hours do you think
it might take to get like a substantial
garage of cars no you know no matter wha
i'm keiko and okuni an OG kangaroo with
a sativa I know more than you do Dino
skyline Alok Mukherjee Kyoto place nitro
not gonna Conoco technically Harley PI
katakana cutter Thomason hi a conqueror
and graduation sports no tsuita barnico
system wa alaa dota unconscionable nani
nani shocker Arnold
atiba ma ma RI tato II know II collect
criminal collection at smelling you are
doriga Raja conferred upon focaccia soon
a mo Yama Sonny so no atari no native
adora cry no decompress liebe liebe dich
renault curio Vasudeva Mathura Coronado
gammer aerocapture to potosi route
opponent a
mother say cocoon on a yoga mat a Hamas
Nkomo lankan disorder a no-shoe Don doko
Saratoga mocks taken again reader an AI
comma Serena's Negron desmos Basra the
feature cazuca Habashi do you know there
so I think it's a really hard question
the answer because it's a part that
we're actually still adjusting you know
so how much you play the game to unlock
things how much distance you need to
drive down lock things that's something
that's still being adjusted so I can't
give you a quite a you know exact answer
right now
but you know because the game it has so
many different features um you know the
main objective of the game might not be
so much to unlock cars anymore
yeah I'm also interested I want to ask
you about VR Jesus far beyond psvr and
I'm curious how you what opportunities
you saw in bringing this franchise that
you work with for so long to virtual
reality no Stella
uh no qualms an obeah GT supposed to be
a dream of a mosquito uh no soy tan
Matra has made the dedicate a on I want
some adult economy doesn't miss oh-ho-ho
the snare I know do you I don't know my
session will hit them onto this spirit
they think a broker joining any tie so
that's great okay so - boqo mother of
mine on so you know
Corning New York the first head mounted
display came out back in 1962 before I
was born
tomato mom was an Enzo
hot the deadest on Oh God my question
mother bear is it expand oh god my PA
said we had Marcus so you know it took
50 years for the psvr to come out you
know finally on the consumer level
product Corral Mozilla so no choji's
sunomono
scoff quest item Odyssey no Carano Bogra
gonna dismiss posted a cricketer Virat
oh so you went when it came out you know
I really wanted to just celebrate the
fact that it finally came out and then
wanted to do everything we can with
GranTurismo Sport sport to support that
todavia ronita associated rapper
contender an actor a non-indigenous
kahneman dynamo abysses river yo yo yo
ii yo captain mode Mrs Shepard ah I know
you love this misquoted - noir we
already tasty - cuckoo cinto tie us the
tighter the two or more carry the more
put it there I know yesterday open
animal-etiquette overnight or move
tonight man so you know but via
supporting VR is actually not very easy
because of the you know in terms of the
visual loads that the device actually
you know moves for the for the system
and and also you know there's the
element of you're trying to set up the
system so that you avoid the players
from becoming you know uncomfortable
playing it and it's I think your
Grandpa's Mosport actually uh you know
is one one of the few games that's been
really properly designed throughout to
you know to properly support VR but it's
still it's still not the best we're
still not at the best booking point we
can be absurd and then I'm curious you
know as say I'm not traditionally into
racing games and then I look at what
racing games there are you know for some
Motorsports seven is on the horizon
GT sports on the horizon you know then
of course there's more arcadey things
like I need for speed payback or you
know the crew - from you stuff but what
is it if I was just getting into racing
games that GT sport offers me that the
other games don't know just enough money
Imam on
Mariano this gameis a nightlight Oh Nima
Congo my horse a seven- Gran Turismo
sport Gracie okay Togo there are no need
for speed Oh that'll eat could eat okay
monster take a Maga and Congo mostly
didn't walk a descoteaux
animus WETA an Akuma Cardinal gaming so
naka naka de I hung up my quad an
e-grants is one massive quantity of
sediment analysis so they're on their
quality I think it boils down to quality
so much the photodiode so that one word
quality sometimes I think I see that
that level quality even beyond the races
themselves there's a certain Sarah
ceremony in unlocking cars and you just
look at the the various UI it seems like
you guys put a lot of thought into the
design of just the menus and even just
like even the lobbies with these
close-up shots of look that look like
almost like expensive watches ticking
down the amount of time before the next
raise of being comment more on that no
no Susan beaucoup Morris on the meaty hi
I know this is only like a : o geeky
techie Domino considered a Hado criminal
unlock you know scatter dr. D and you I
know designed a team you know super cool
anokhin guy right there design is a
little chaotic ETA on Tony and
robbiedinho clothes Kumal close-up today
Acacio ya know
Takayuki know and commercial material
Natsuko know can realize the design that
you know suits Artemus so can stated I
can guess is yeah I'm glad you you feel
that okay so my guy taco
tenon design is taken I told that title
so I came Irina a day
because unless you really take care of
every individual detail properly you
don't get that type of overall
experience is that what you meant when
you were talking about like quality
setting GT sport apart like could you
expand on that what you mean in terms of
out like the polish or like when you say
quality is what sets it apart
could you expand on that so Jamie the
more on sucking on top of quality - you
shut down since another to moon cycle
from a game you know Anna sighs you know
mommy jockey aagadu between dr. D high
enough so - so it's a pointed dodo much
like a Ducati go to Moscow see a loss
it's my state that Moscow squashes Ned
Sakana a no como se de boku wa
presentation Dan DOCA Mariah Vento diet
and eskimo ma design no process design
Nastasia de production most a cigar say
yeah extremization on station up there
no Simon if I'm in cafes even other
snake okay so yeah it's a hard question
to answer but let me try um you know III
you know between the live events I also
gave in presentation on the stage and we
talked about you know they're being a
design in the development is a design
stage there's a production stage is an
optimization stage and then there is the
refinement stage the Suja walk design
products on there matter what you know
and so you know video game necessity
variable a normal video game production
usually just ends with the design stage
and the production stage and that's it
mother what do the mall some
optimization on stage you know Monica
bag radical it is heretic by go okay so
only oftentimes I think you know what
the games are released it you know it
may be in the middle of the optimization
still got a budget if I put up at 66
emotional assault on the show and Tiki
five in GT 6 for titles that that were
that way but uh mom quality no comedy
you thought so if you look at the
quality curve this is no we had a
release like right here okay so the
conga this time
not funny Anurag amamori day ahead of
our most acidic on credit
yeah so we asked Sony you know you
please just give us a bit more time to
write really do it right so slick
Antonio tear optimizes on tour if I
meant oh no no point Nausicaa Oh screw
the Sunday just porque no cab okay phone
are on the side and so by doing that we
were able to you get to make more time
for the optimization and refinement and
really you know the last end of that
that quality curve really shoots up you
know at the very end she okay buddy
cocodes good Punk garnets critic up and
asuna silver go Santo cut what up and
that's the part that you know I really
wanted to secure for our new title or
for this one woman came out and that was
presumably why the game was delayed
right to make time for that optimization
ok so don't optimize so codifying suitum
any mother game already an oak written
exactly my home divert video game a
South Dakota Oregon Country night could
I add tamada you know not Mohito porcini
not pitched a Inomata open Aikido karate
kodomo no no no yeah because you know
again video game development really has
no end to it if if you really think
about it because you can always make
something better you can always you know
work on more details I am curious you
know a lot of games nowadays you know
they release and then developers kind of
you know fix things in the aftermath do
you think that's a bad practice in
general do you think more developers
should be kind of doing what you did
with GT sport and making sure the game
is polished as possible before releasing
it despite the fact that it you know
delays are very difficult from a
developer standpoint it cost a lot of
money resources time but in general do
you think it would be better off for the
industry if more people waited like you
did
the game Yoko naka de Amalia I set the
game you did east okay to you know kick
on a psyche one more game adidas Alta a
Tony I know logic so that study I don't
know now study shows echo to echo is a
signifier sodium Ottawa area no I'm a
yolk una coca-cola to Oscar
my gran turismo sports me tiny Santo an
Ahmadi dismally Nemo mega keyaki tei I
know psychology Oh tidy that's okay it
was hard okay co-op I did develop a
toast Eva I had to know my chicken mocha
cut the D so small I got the on okay
Arno so tell me Noah and Nobita Nobita
because canal boom of a little on the
scale or a Tony a no is a nickel a
burrito video game and okie Pocahontas
unitary samosa coconut de vino de Donna
is anointed by July no disco knee MOSFET
or comet a there is a a potato snack
Thomas Oreo walks the US Route the
photon I know are monocoque Tonya got
the mass net have a portent of common
and then I got the you know cylinder
scatter more and so in a compared to
compared to the Past the the games have
become so much bigger in scale is so
much more complex and I don't you know
nowadays I don't think it's possible
anymore to do what we used to do before
where you have one disc where everything
there is no updates afterwards sure that
everything on that disc has to work
properly you know on your first try but
I know nowadays because the complexity
is kill it's it's almost become
impossible to do that okay oh no David
802 photo Baba Oh celica GT 500 token in
Pokhara Gothamist I'm the CEO and the
and what's called the day one updates
nowadays is I say I think something that
we actually vetted back in gt5 right
right so did I you don't not like to
look at they were output it also doing
that and since then a lot of different
titles have one you've gone through and
and released a one updates you know to
their titles so there
oh no no no canal the critical donor
there are potatoes native screw the
title - so quad but you know if it was
possible I think that it will be better
to be able to make the game without a
day one update so so leave our mode is
Obama tacos OH so DePalma
and in a best-case scenario you know
that would that would be it you know no
updates in you know process commodity
sports la gt500 gt6 no only kotoba and
don't istikhara honto sacani decide this
is a video considered to unit so it's
cricketer austenite this photo are you
don't just attend a concert elaborate
open and so in that respect you know
Gran Turismo sport is not going to be
like gt5 or GT 6 where you know half a
year after the game actually launches
the game is being completed sure I don't
think that would be a case for GT sport
you ready you know complete title
morning releases great I think that's
all the questions I had but yeah I thank
you Eleonora Muji's thank you so much
for joining us doc I thank you so much
for translating and we hope you enjoy
the rest of the show but yeah we if
you're watching from home we will be
continuing with Final Fantasy 14 the
expansion storm but right after this but
again thank you so much for joining us
we hope you enjoy the rest the show and
we'll see you around
you